Germy the germ is very mean...
...and so small, he can't be really seen.
He's green and stinky and one bad dude.
He even likes to hide in food.
In the water and on the ground, Germy the germ is all around.
He's in the air and on your skin.
He'll make you sick if he gets in.
An ache, an itch, a cold, a flu,...
...Germy loves to cause trouble in you.
If he gets in your body, he'll have a party...
...and invite his germ friends Jim, Bob and Marty.
Next thing you know, you'll be feeling rotten,...
...all because of one thing forgotten.
"What's that?" you ask.
Is it really so easy to keep from feeling sick and queasy?
Just wash your hands before you eat...
...to keep Germy the germ from getting his treat.
And wash your hand after you play,...
...so Germy the germ will get washed away.